finira-t-elle par trouver un port
d'attache bien sûr j'ai d'autres
certitudes j'ai d'autres
habitudes et d'autres que toi sont venus
les lèvres tendre et les mains nues bien
sûr bien sûr j'ai murmuré leur nom j'ai
caressé leur front et j'ai partagé le
frisson
mais
en aventure de train en train de Bort en
Bort jamais encore je te le jure je n'ai
pu oublié ton corps mais aventure mon
aventure de train en train de bord en
bord je n'ai pu fermer ma
blessure je t'aime encore bien sûr du
soir au matin blême depuis j'ai dit je
t'aime
et d'autres que toi sont venus marquer
leur dents sur ma peau nu bien
sûr bien sûr pour trouver le repos j'ai
caressé le repos
elles m'ont même trouvé
[Musique]
beau
mais
d'aventure en aventure de train en train
for en por jamais encore je te le jure
je n'ai plus oublié ton corps mais
d'aventure en aventure de train en train
de port en port je n'ai pu fermer ma
blessure je t'aime encore bien sûr j'ai
joué de mes armes j'ai joué de leurs
larmes
[Musique]
entre le bonsoir et l'adieu souvent pour
rien souvent par jeu bien
sûr bien sûr j'ai redit à mi voix tous
les mots que pour toi j'ai dit pour la
première
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maisenture en aventure de train en train
de forort en forort jamais encore je te
le jure je n'ai plus oublié ton C mais
aventure enaventure de train en terin de
port en port je n'ai pu fermer ma
blessure parce que je t'aime je t ime je
t'aime encore je t'aime
encore